ok les gars
ils sont cinq dans une pièce non défini
du bâtiment aura ils ont une banque on
viens rapide semble efficace
ça inclut pas de nourriture et à
l'arrière
arrivé sur site dans 5 4
[Musique]
allez hop et un même toit
personnes qui arrivent soit l'entrée si
calais rapidement tourner à lévis les
hologrammes chicago bulls barricades
[Musique]
sur contrat
le
[Musique]
les boss des bosses watch vélo
c'est plus viège qui bouge et 20 kg
ok les gars faites gaffe à vos petits
culs mais l'équipe sait quoi s'inquiéter
[Musique]
il ya plus faire face à nous des
chapelets par l'air bien reçu vous les
avez trouvés
je pense que
[Musique]
et
coucou
[Musique]
pour l'équipe on a perdu le signal deux
attaquants
soit
[Musique]
et ben non